[Musique]
vous êtes tous assurés moi aussi je suis
assuré mais est ce que ça me rassure
d'être assuré pas vraiment pourquoi
parce que quand je démonte le mécanisme
de l'assurance il me faut deux jambes
un individu qui analysent ces risques
qui décide de ce qu'il peut garder pour
lui et de ce qu'il doit partager avec
d'autres
le deuxième élément dans une opération
l'assurance et l'assureur alors
l'assureur c'est celui qui va organiser
le partage du risque
et qu'est ce qu'il apporte il apporte
une garantie que la transaction entre
l'assuré et la victime va être exécutée
et surtout qu'il sera là au terme
solvable pour pouvoir réaliser
l'opération
à ce stade de l'analyse de l'opération
de l'assurance on se dit ah bah tiens on
était dans un univers d'incertitude et
péan tout d'un coup miracle c'est
certain je serai indemnisés moi je suis
étonné pourquoi est-ce que je suis
certain d'être indemnisés alors on
approfondit et on se rend compte qu'en
fait cette assurance dans notre pays en
tout cas dans 80% des cas allez
obligatoire d'une part et d'autre part
il ne m'apparaît pas évident moi
consommateur de base ce que coûte cette
certitude bien je vous annonce que
lorsque vous payer 200 euros de primes
ttc en moyenne vous ne recevrez que 100
euros d'indemnités 100%
c'est une opération et une certitude qui
coûte un peu cher
en tout cas à mon goût cette solidarité
imposée en fait à des effets pervers
alors le premier effet c'est qu'on vous
dit vous avez un tiers de confiance
mais à aucun moment vous avez choisi de
lui faire confiance
d'ailleurs vous lui faites pas confiance
faire confiance à quelqu'un c'est
prendre un risque et la société dans
lequel il y aurait zéro risque
je vous rassure tout de suite existe pas
il faut faire avec et la gérer
par ailleurs vous avez ce phénomène
d'obligations qui fait qu' on ne me
demande plus mon avis je prends cette
assurance parce qu'on m'oblige de la
france donc je ne sais pas quelles sont
mes besoins d'assurance puisqu'il me
sont imposés donc en fait l'assurance
obligatoire déresponsabilise il dernier
aspect il est beaucoup plus embêtant
parce que l'assureur c'est une espèce de
d'abstraction sans personnalité et cet
assureur qui n'a pas de personnalité
comment est-ce que je réagis vis-à-vis
de lui si moi je décidé de voler ma
grand-mère ou d'aller prendre le dans le
portefeuille de ma mère je fais un vol à
une personne c'est concret ça m'engage
ça me taraudait après en revanche si je
décide de voler mon assureur ou l'état
c'est une fraude ce n'est pas un vol
puisque cet état je le connais pas je
connais pas sa personne qu'est-ce que ça
induit chez l'assuré c'est qu'en fait à
vous m'avez fait payer 200 euros de
primes ttc et ben moi je vais faire en
sorte de recevoir 200 euros d'indemnités
et non pas les centres dont on parlait
tout à l'heure
finalement qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
que la fraude c'est la variable
d'ajustement de l'assuré pour arriver au
prix qu'il considère comme juste
d'ailleurs en parlant de fraude et tous
vu dans le métro les grandes campagnes
sur les voyageurs sans titre de
transport
depuis qu'il ya eu cette campagne vous
avez des propositions sur le net
pouvoir partager dans une communauté les
cas où on se fait prendre et où on doit
payer l'amendé
l'être humain a beaucoup d'imagination
mais on peut se dire que puisqu'on est
capable d'organiser des communautés sur
le numérique ou sur une plate forme pour
pouvoir partager une amende ce qui n'est
pas forcément une bonne raison on doit
quand même capable de pouvoir organiser
des communautés numériques pour lesquels
on peut partager un risque ensemble avec
des gens qu'on a choisi le numérique
aujourd'hui ils ouvrent des champs
d'application à des techniques qui sont
pas tout à fait nouvelle qui existent
déjà depuis un certain temps mais on
n'arrivait pas les appliquer à les
mettre en oeuvre
alors dans ces techniques on vous en a
déjà parlé la dual big data dans cette
technique vous avez le fameux blocs
chaîne alors bon c'est un peu mystérieux
mais pour dire simplement le bloc chaîne
c'est un processus qui utilise de la
cryptographie et de l'algorithmie pour
pouvoir permettre à une communauté de
valider elle même les transactions qui
se passe entre elles qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'à va
finalement en utilisant bien ces quatre
outils je peux arriver à créer des
communautés dans lesquelles les gens se
font confiance auquel les gens décident
d'adhérer et surtout dont la monnaie des
changes le prix de la qualité de ces
transactions est adaptée au profil de la
communauté aujourd'hui a assuré
il n'a plus les moyens d'utiliser le
système assurantiel dans lequel on lui
fait payer 200 euros pour 100 euros
d'indemnités donc bah il est comme nous
tous il se promène sur le net il se dit
ah bah tiens qu'est ce que je pourrais
faire
qu'est ce qu'on me propose et puis
maintenant il tombe sur des gens qui lui
disent ah bah si vous voulez vous mettre
ensemble avec des gens avec lesquels
vous
santé un point commun vous pouvez vous
réunir et par une cotisation financer un
processus de blocs chaîne qui va en fait
sécuriser vos opérations et surtout qui
va les valider et vous permettre de
pratiquer sa à un prix plus juste
pourquoi le prix il peut être plus juste
une première raison c'est que votre
automatisation et votre validation par
les membres de la communauté elle-même
du coup permet une désintermédiation
donc le coût de cette intermédiation et
est mis de côté mais le deuxième aspect
c'est que comme vous avez décidé d'y
rentrer la fraude qui était une variable
d'ajustement
nenê but une variable d'ajustement et
donc c'est une deuxième source de du
prix plus justes donc on peut créer des
communautés qui permette que les gens se
fassent confiance de travailler avec un
prix plus juste et d'exercer sa
responsabilité
ça ça s'appelle un peu le principe de
subsidiarité
ça veut dire quoi le principe de
subsidiarité vous faites confiance aux
communautés de base pour régler leurs
problèmes localement mais surtout vous
fait confiance sur le fait que quand l
appellerons l'échelon supérieur à zorro
épuisé la totalité des solutions locales
et donc ces communautés du numérique qui
peuvent s'auto gérer
c'est une solution de consolider la mise
en oeuvre du principe de subsidiarité
c'est pourquoi je prends l'option rêve
pour le vivre ensemble demain
ah ah